I I know some people though who are just
like super like you know anal
about that stuff but it's
whatever I saw that one what is it they
are a fan of your
content this is presuming assuming
before this this is for us before before
you get in a relationship yeah I would
imagine so yeah CU obviously like after
you I'm sure I would hope my partner is
a fan of my first date first date
kind of thing you find out first first
dat first date a fan of your content oh
are we all going to have the same
answer for this yeah yeah I think so I
think so ready 3 2
1 I'm riding it right now yeah I got red
too it's red it's were you going to put
beige at the beginning no no no I just I
was right I'm an idiot um I
think that uh you know fact fun fact uh
Mark Rober his wife is a fan was a fan
really uh yeah I think there's a there's
tons of examples where it's gone well
and it's fine and there are tons of
examples where it's gone horribly wrong
I think it's just a it's it gives people
a normally there's normally a bad
connotation around it specifically with
just YouTubers in general because like
rock stars or whatever they don't they
was never a bad I'm I'm saying
this more like a personal level my gut
reaction to like if I'm on like a first
date they're like oh by the way I like I
really like your stuff I'm like not aan
of that that means you know more about
me than I do about you and that makes me
uncom some kind of like weird parasocial
look about you where they know they
think they know a lot about you through
the videos which in a lot of cases
there's a lot that doesn't get shown on
camera okay this is better or worse this
is such an like my person feeling no but
the Nuance to this question is so
numerous like but that's every question
yeah and like being a I could have
watched five of G's videos and I could
be like yeah I'm a fan of G's videos but
I don't know anything about G I just
know that he's made some videos that I
enjoyed there's so many different layers
of this question I think that because
you know you hear about this all the
time I think YouTubers who date fans
it's generally not a good thing but I
think it's fine it's just if they do
some up yeah it can it can
work as with anything if you treat it
like an adult and you're not like Tak
advantage of like this Dynamic that you
have but for me it just like it would
make me uncomfortable because I want to
come into a relation in like equal stand
there needs to be that Joy of finding
stuff out about each other you know
you're like what the why you the
rues cube that's crazy really like
probably like one in a million scenario
but hypothetically speaking Yeah if
there was a girl who was a fan of you
but they don't use social media what as
in like they watch YouTube but they
don't do twitch uh Twitter Instagram
Facebook any of that kind of stuff would
that change no it' be a little bit
better i' feel a bit better about it but
I I still would feel a bit like how much
have you seen yeah you see that one
where I look like all the time
which is all of my videos yeah that's
just like a fifth date kind of thing
yeah like I think most YouTubers can
agree this is kind of a red flag for on
different levels um well yeah I mean a
lot of our stuff is so personal and our
content often we share so much of
ourselves so I think that they yeah like
you said they would know so much about
you yeah already yeah so I think it' be
we Paro um but haveu not so much though
it's not so much if they just watched
your main Channel they wouldn't know
sure they wouldn't know much about you
yeah I mean I now I think like there's a
whole different like Dynamic since ever
since I saw trash taste yeah exactly
right like this like if I if I just made
music on YouTube and never showed my
face I think I'd be like whatever yeah
that' be different cuz then like if I VI
with them and it was really chill they
wouldn't know anything about me oh they
like my music that's cool yeah and then
okay okay this is
so they are a fan of trash taste instant
red flag get them out of here why we
have they know too much this is why we
have to go with our God don't
reason logic it we can Logic the
out of all of these oh my God red and
I'm sticking by all right cool turn
box oh
god
um wow of course I got this one wears
the same outfit a
[Music]
lot yes SE over drip company what do you
think Joey what do you think uh okay I
have I have My reasonings for
this uh all
right wears the same outfit a lot yeah
we don't know anyone who does that no no
one no one I know all right 3 2 1 beige
green green white
bro I mean if you got a great outfit and
you're confident in it rock it
what if it's not a great outfit yeah I
mean I'll just tell them okay but what
if it's like they think it's
awesome but you are just like that a it
Chief and they don't change their mind
about it as a great concern um I would
hope that I have fallen in love with
every aspect of them including their
outfit choices and then then this is a
win because I like it a lot and they're
wearing it all the time okay here here's
the thing here's the thing you you go on
three dates they the same and they wear
the same outfit on three okay like two
that would be
me I I you know you at least being like
you know I wore the twitch shirt yes
purple shirt but next one I'm going to
wear the trash T-shirt If it's a banger
outfit it's a banger outfit what if it's
not a banger outfit odds are it is if
they're wearing it back to back yeah
yeah so so like You' be surprised man
really I've never heard of such a
thing speciically you only wear the
outfit if it's great surprised I mean I
probably mentioned it I'll probably uh
you know give a bit of banter about it
but this is way more common for guys
than than uh women in general though
yeah yeah I think guys tend to wear the
same outfits a lot more yeah no
definitely it's but like I I feel like
even on dates you know me you on dates
you're just like very obviously very
conscious about yeah if you found
something that's comfortable for you
though and you you really feel great in
it and uh why not like do it rock it hey
what I thing to think about yeah I put
beige because that was me before I met
Ary I used to just wear the same clothes
all the time because I didn't
care about what I wore Disney
adult no just classic Australian wearing
the same
like then you know cuz like Aki was
super into fashion I got into it because
of her so like I'm thinking about that
now in the opposite side of things being
like well if I like clothes which I do
now and if my partner say for example
wore the same all the time that
would get me excited to be like let's
try on some let's see what you like
you know and that would give me an
excuse to bond with them as it did for
us so yeah that's why you just took my
like anime and movie answer Joey
what you're like this is it this is my
bonding chance it's like a red flag for
that suddenly with clothes you're like o
it's a little you can avoid anime you
can't avoid clothes you know well I'm
trying my best speak for yourself jery I
know you've been trying your best yeah
all right
wait wait that's it's you yeah I was
going to tell you now he's too deep in
the draw that's whatever all right here
we
go they text you every
day oh that's a good one they text you
every is this like what period of the
are we like first date territory just
all from first date to like does it make
a difference current I think it does you
think 100% I'm thinking about it
actually doesn't text you every day do
text you every day text they text you
every day they text you every day for me
it depends
H okay I'm going to I'm going to my
reasoning all right yeah I'm going to go
with my gut all right all right 3 two 1
I said none I said green I said red oh
okay I said none because it really
depends on the frequency like when we
say every day like how often every day
are we talking like every couple of
hours like every five minutes it's very
different right if it's only like a
couple of times a day then I think
that's fine I think there's nothing
wrong I need time to
marinate I got to listen if you if you
that's an out of context clip I need
time to like really know how that I'm
feeling it and the only way I know that
is if I I have a moment where I don't
talk to you and I still think about you
you know what I mean that really lets me
know that I I really it's something
special see this might be different cuz
I was in a long-term relationship where
texting was the only real way to stay in
contact but to me I feel like sometimes
I was guil to this in school where I
would build I would want to talk to the
person every day not because I wanted to
but out of habit and that I I it was a
thing that we both did and we almost I
almost felt like hostage by it but I
felt that if they didn't text me I would
get like anxious and I and I felt like
that was a bad trait that I developed
but how often would you text um um it'd
be a fair amount yeah it'd be like a few
times a day right and I didn't like that
that I felt reliant on that right and
then when you feel like you needed to
because yeah and then I I realized I was
so much happier when I felt that like
there was no small talk and
when we'd hang out it'd be really good
and we'd occasionally text in between
but there was no expectation that it had
to be there every day and I like that a
lot and that's to me when I really know
that it's s really like uh something
really worth pursuing it's like it's
like those friends that you have where
you could not talk to each other for
like months on end but but when you meet
them again IRL it's like nothing Chang
I'm that person yeah me too me too I'm
like that too I don't want to text I'm
like hey if you want a call let's have a
call yeah but I don't really want to
text much but now I'll be like you know
if I'm if I'm with someone for a very
long time yeah just to text me and like
yeah how's your day going going good all
right well I I'll see you on the weekend
or something that's where I'm kind of
that's where I get to so I do like the
daily text after a while but in the
initial getting together period of like
that first few months I don't want to
text every day I I I need know that we
can operate outside of each other that's
very important to me right for me uh I
just like get in my own head a lot uh I
don't know if like shed that weakness
gone I I don't know if any I don't know
if any guy gets this uh but it's just
like sometimes you overthink whether
like the frequency of the text and I've
kind of realized that I would rather
just know that someone like I'm
in someone's mind especially for like
thinking no matter what in no matter
what period of the relationship is I
would love to know that I'm in someone's
thoughts thoughts and prayers uh I'm in
someone's thoughts um kind of like you
know on on on like a day-to-day basis
because if I like someone they're going
to be in my thoughts you know and
sometimes I'm I'm that kind of guy who
you guys know I'm horrible at
this so I need someone to just
message me so that I know you're both
being held hostage by your
anxieties you're both being held hostage
by the equal anxiety you share of
wanting to be wanted by each other yeah
so I need someone to balance me out I
need I I need someone to balance me out
the true Chad moment is when you realize
that you both are happy together and you
don't need to know you don't need to
have each other's attention constantly
yeah no no I totally agree with that you
can be dependent and independent at the
same time being independent is such an
important thing and that I I learned to
you know sometimes also like you know RV
trip I'm live constantly and then I'm I
then have to when the camera go off I
got to I got to eat sleep and then
prepare the stuff for the next day that
be like a 5day thing where I just can't
I I just don't have the capacity to have
a conversation yeah um and so it's it's
just like I need to know that you're not
going to freak out if I if I'm just kind
of like not really there for five days
right yeah yeah no I I no I totally get
that as well um I kind of like I kind of
just think that I think the especially
in like the initial periods right
there's so much this dance about
should I text should I not text uh blah
blah blah blah what am I talking too
much am I talking too little and I think
if they want to talk they're going to
talk and if I don't want to talk
like if I don't want to talk back
because I'm just not vibing or if it's
too much then that's just going to be an
indicator for me sure you know so for me
I would rather someone text me every day
when whenever they actually mean it when
they actually mean it absolutely uh so
that I like I kind of know their
intentions and I know like what they
want and I know if I want to pursue
something as well or if I want to text
back cuz most of the time if they text
every day uh I'm going to be like if I
really like them I'm going to text back
and it's it's going to be you know it's
going to have I think the key thing here
is that I I felt that it wasn't the
question wasn't phrased as like it's
nice to talk every day it's more like
they have to talk every day right yeah
which I think is a big difference
obviously it's nice to talk every day
but I never ever want to have that
feeling that like I need to talk to them
every day I feel like that that can
breed some toxic uh toxic uh kind of
traits in the relationship right yeah
that they kind of need to be around each
other constantly oh yeah yeah I I
totally I think just just that some
sometimes on busy days just a single
text is enough just just know sometimes
you know like I I'm talking like
personally sometimes I have like similar
days where I have no time at all
where I'm working all day but just
knowing it's like Hey Sydney how's your
day been and she's been like it's good
I'm making dinner I'm like you know
that's all you need that's that's all I
need you know that's that's that's what
I want so yeah green flag for me yeah
very very different depending on
personality types I feel yes all right
you oh it's me he it oh okay all right
what's the next one
G oh God you're
laughing
what they are ask to um they ask for
your phone
passcode uh normal uh I guess um maybe
not normal but it happens yeah it it
does happen I mean do we even have to do
the reveal I think we already know right
it's red it's red privacy is
very important in uh you need to have
some semblance of it absolutely um you
can have nothing to hide yeah and I
think it's valid to to just not not want
to give that out I think people who ask
of their partners for their phone uh you
know passwords because they're afraid
that like their partner is hiding
something is just projecting themselves
onto their partner like like people who
do that clearly have been in a past
where like they've had to hide something
themselves and so you know because they
have stuff to hide they think well I
have stuff to hide so maybe my partner
also has stuff to hide too maybe I
should get his phone code so like that's
just immediate red flat it's it's like
to me um I've actually experienced this
with like previous relationships
actually um it's it's almost like The
Catch 22 you know it's like what came
first the chicken or the egg except it's
like oh you trust them so you should
have no problem giving them your phone
passcode but you if you have nothing to
hide you can give it but like it like to
me in my experience it builds a very
something toxic kind of trust system it
is it is the wrong kind of mentality
where you know if you trust your partner
you should have no problem giving them
your passcode but if they trust you they
wouldn't ask for your pod code a pass
code it's it's it's like a you've got
nothing to hide is the the the scummiest
defense to to overreach in the history
of overreaching because you know the of
course you got nothing to hide but also
privacy is allowed yeah you know like
you are allowed to have things private
and that is a right that you get to have
as a human being I don't want you
looking I don't want you snooping
through my files without my
permission in any situation do I have to
explain every meme on my phone
no like there's a I think if you ask I
have to explain my Google ass to you
this would be a uh a relationship Ender
for me I think if someone asked me of
this I think this this would and if they
were pushing it after I said no I think
I'd that would yeah that' be a
relationship end yeah I I think so too I
think people who do this uh don't don't
do it yeah it never goes well yeah I
think you know there's a fallacy in like
every relationship where you have to
share every single part of yourselves
with your partner and I think a good
important thing about relationships is
that you're just acknowledging that
you're individual people um with your
own like wants and privacy and whatever
and you are comfortable with that I feel
like a lot of couples get insecure if
they don't if they if they don't have
like prove to El that like oh I know
everything about my partner we we are
like one soul and I'm like H to me
that's not like that's not what a
balanced relationship is in my opinion
you know no I agree I agree with that
all right that was an easy uh clean red
flag sweep Clean Sweep baby I hope
everyone at home also said red all right
this is the last one last one there is
only one more here we go and I was
feeling like we had a natural conclusion
as well
yeah
she
uh what the how they written this
she a low but I think it's a 10 oh wait
oh she a 10 oh my God she a low she
alone I was like I was like what it was
formatted really weird but put okay yeah
it really she's a 10 sorry I I was
trying to read this and I was like is
that my crazy it looks format really
bizarre she's a tber put milk before
cereal wait what uh she puts milk before
her cereal she's a 10 but she puts milk
before her cereal and you said Point
Crow something it's a point tweet that
was it okay so this is a tweet from
point Crow fellow content creator yeah
who said she's a 10 but she pours milk
before her cereal
okay how do I answer
this all
right okay all right ready three two one
green clearly a red flag guys green I
don't give a about how you pull
your to the streets Joey be some things
you will not be in my househ are
important milk before cereal couldn't
give two fat rats asses about how you
pour your cereal you're a 10 joy we have
rules for a reason civilization was
built on reason and structure and if
people don't follow that structure
civilization crushes Jo a cow Who
provided that milk give a about how
it's
who doesn't like to follow a rigid set
of rules until today well guess I'm a
Rebel then to the streets I
don't give a how you pour your
cereal no I don't really
care I do think it's up but I
wouldn't end a relationship it's a bit
beige it's like a beige green why would
you insist on having a worse experience
I'd uh call them out for it I just don't
really care I'm like if that's how you
like it that's fine just don't make me
do the same it's like putting the
milk in the tea before you've put the te
in it's like why are you doing this
you're doing this so much hard of
yourself I just think to myself oh
you're lost I'm still eating
cereal a delicious a big deal no I don't
really give a